gentlemen we're live we are officially
live episode number 95 phil heath just
walks in come on in phil come on in phil
come on in phil
we did no just rolls up making rolls
that's how you make it here you go
uh the the podcast you guys did over the
weekend mr olympia 200 000 people tuned
in worldwide to listen to and i was
amazing dude we missed you
yeah because we were thinking that you
were going to do a pose down close down
pose now with mario
and and roy
let me tell you
roy did a good job roy did a great job
you know he was a
former npc competitor he competed at the
amateur show actually it was one of my
shows don't make this about roy please
let's make this but he did a really i'm
not even going to leave a good job as
well make this about you and look at it
it's all about muscle matting over here
this dude forgotten more about the uh
the human body than we'll ever shout out
to big romney for winning you know shut
up
for winning and brandon curry looked a
little bit pissed off because i think he
he thought he could have won it and uh
i like i like curry's attitude you know
uh rami that's back to back for him
which is cool to see that that's huge
yeah was he the favorite yeah by far he
was a favorite he was he lived up to
expectations he's two-time mr olympian
now right yeah i mean shout out to big
rammy
you know um
i've said this before but uh after he
won last year i made sure that i told
him you have to come in better because
next year they're all kind of gunning
for you and it's always hard
that camera is blurry it's always hard
to blend it's always hard to defend
right you win one but it's hard to
defend yeah
so uh shout out to ramy but uh you know
what i'm i'm happy that brandon curry
showed a little
discuss with this place i like that i
like it too yeah you know you shouldn't
just be happy oh i play second i love
that no man you should be pissed nobody
was more pissed than hottie man yeah
you know that's a
look
i think during that webcast like we all
thought that hottie had a major chance i
believe even sean ray and richard sperry
while they were doing theirs had hottie
as the most conditioned guy in the show
and he was pretty complete it might have
been a size issue you know because he
was definitely giving up
i mean jeez did you know that he uh that
randy can you put up the picture sky
just to see the top three mr olympia did
you know that ramy weighed in at the uh
at the press conference at 303 wow
he was in a suit mind you but
i mean you're pushing
300 pounds 300 pounds is that the
biggest ever to win it or no was ronnie
still bigger than winning ronnie was
and what were you when you won it oh
gosh
no i probably look 260 but i was 248.
wow
okay so i mean you know howdy is
definitely on he's on the third he's on
the far right yeah for anyone that
doesn't know but honey gave like
a really good argument as to being at
least second in this you know because
look at the quads you know compared to
everybody else it's just more deep
separation but
you know i think when you do the quarter
turns and you do all the other poses i
can understand why the judges picked
grammy you know i mean look at his he
looks he like dwarfs these these massive
men look the size of this guy who the
one in the middle we're in the middle
yeah that's big romney for you yeah
that's big romney did he officially
change his name to big romney that's his
name they called him that so i met
romney like 11 years ago in kuwait
and he was
just getting ready to turn pro i believe
he's egyptian
yes okay or i think he just turned pro i
remember seeing him uh compete i thought
i remember talking to dennis james i go
this guy
just turned pro he's like yes i go
okay i gotta get back in the gym this is
a guy that definitely if he gets it
together i mean he's gonna be mr olympia
someday and he did it twice so congrats
to big ramy again
i know uh one phrase an egyptian because
there was an egyptian girl in high
school that was super into it so i
learned that
now it's which i guess was uh a
bastardization of like i love you i have
no idea did it work no no it actually it
actually means a complete difference
all right let's get into some stores
let's get into some stores okay we got a
lot of things to cover chappelle got a
lot of backlash for a couple comments he
made john gruden fired slash resignation
phil's got a few comments i thought i
got some thoughts on that google google
will no longer allow climate deniers to
make money on youtube uh gas prices hit
all-time high seven years southwest
airlines cancels nearly 2000 flights and
they blame it on weather they blame it a
lot of other things but
they try to blame it on the rain but
it's it's definitely something else
tyson fury went against wilder i thought
it was a sick fight man i watched that
fight i was blown away
cnn uh comment was made unhinged cnn gop
drum dumping anthrax in our water fox
news is killing people that was said by
who brian
the human thumb brian stelter yeah
fantastic commentary he's got there more
than 130 countries reach deal on
corporate minimum tax which is
what we talked about a couple months ago
donald trump will never be president
ever again says renowned
uh poster frank luntz china's ji vows
peaceful uh unification with taiwan days
after sending the surge of warplanes
near the island de blasio phase out new
york city gifted and talented program
uh and a few other stories that we got
here but i say we start off with the de
blasio story so de blasio to phase out
if you want to go to page nine
uh
yeah page nine de blasio in new york
city they just want to make that city
better and better to attract more people
to move there so de blasio to phase out
new york city gifted and talented
programs this is a new york times story
he on friday he unveiled a plan to
overhaul gifted and talented education
new york city elementary schools calling
for sweeping changes into a highly
selective program that has been widely
criticized for exa exacerbating
segregation in the nation's largest
school system the mayor's action attempt
to address what the city has known for
decades it's gifted and talented program
has control to racially segregated
classrooms and schools for thousands of
students nationwide citywide de blasio
has criticized for not taking forceful
action to fulfill his promise of
tackling inequality in public schools
the announcement comes just three months
before he must leave office because of
term limits putting the fate of the plan
in the hands of his successor adam
thoughts so let me get this straight he
just wants everyone in the new york city
school system just to be in regular
classes yeah no more vpn honors so as
someone who has taken regular classes uh
something called academic excellence
i've been in honors classes and i've
been ap classes
for anyone that's ever been in school
knows that's a huge freaking difference
to give you a case example i was by far
and away the smartest person in regular
classes when i took them and i was by
far and away the dumbest person in ap
classes when i took those classes so i
had to like find my bearings i had to
figure out like i was actually pretty
good at history i couldn't read so good
so i had to get into regular like the
fact that you're just going to lump
everyone are you saying into one class
are you saying you wish you would have
never taken any ap classes so you
wouldn't have felt inferior no no no
it's it's you got to understand that
bottom line is i think this is a
horrible idea i don't know if they're
looking for equality or uh what's the
term that everyone's using diversity
equity including maybe inclusive on a
serious note how did it feel when you
went i've never taken ap i've never
taken honors on 1.8 esl lifelong esl efl
when you went from uh regular class to
ap and honors what what did you feel as
a student well
look
when i was in regular classes so i i
went from public school my whole life
and then i got a scholarship so i was in
private school last few years so they
just kind of were like you did good in
public school we're going to throw you
in honors classes all across the board
at a school called miami country day in
miami and it's a it's kind of like a
westminster it's a good school
and i realized oh [ __ ] i i i i i'm
french we had a hedge fund guy over
that's extremely successful in greenwich
and they were trying to put their kids
in miami country they and they were
raving about the school grade school
yeah i'm very like lifelong contacts
great but the point is this i realized
very quickly i was good at some stuff
and not good at other stuff and then i
went down to regular and the bottom line
is this
i don't understand this idea
kids work their asses off to excel in
school now you're gonna have super super
smart kids just sitting there
literally dumbfounded being in regular
classes i think this is a horrible idea
so is that so basically are they saying
that the curriculum will not be ap
is that right
making it easier making it easier for
you to not feel inferior to others who
are so they don't want us to compete
yeah yeah that's exactly what it is and
i think essentially that's wrong so if
you put yourself in the
let's let's look at both sides of the
coin who are the kids that are like i
feel
you know inferior i feel like i'm being
not included in the smart kids so i
protect my feelings and put everyone in
my class that's that kid i guess or the
probably not even the kid their parents
i would assume now think about the kid
that's like look i'm working my freaking
ass off here i read every single night
i'm strategizing i'm improving my kids
my parents have raised me right and now
you want me to go to the just
regular
class how does that help me how does
that get me ap credits in college here's
what it makes no sense here's what i'm
thinking about which kid actually wants
this like look i'm the other kid right
i'm the kid at the bottom of the
uh what do you call it like you know
i'm the bottom of the regular class yeah
so like like not the be like you're
saying you were the best in the regular
class i'm the bottom of the regular
class okay you're not excelling i wonder
if they did this would this make me feel
more confident would this make me feel
more special would this make me feel
more like oh my gosh thank you so much
for doing this because i was feeling
very you know weak
i don't even think those kids get hair
yeah but go and think about doing those
kids even care you're still going to
grade on a curve right that's kid's
still going to get a deer because gerard
and i both wrote this
exactly i just wrote it just now and you
wrote it yeah you're gonna still the
smart kids are gonna get a's
are gonna knock you out
it goes beyond that it goes beyond that
guys i mean what's happening here is you
know the white savior complex this is
you know the white liberal activist
who's you know she's in class and she's
the teacher and she's like well if every
kid just had the resources that
these kids in the ap classes had they'd
all have the same capacity they're they
are completely and totally incapable of
seeing differences between human beings
they're incapable in seeing that some
people may excel in a and not excel and
b all it is is access to to opportunity
and the resources and we'll all be
exactly the same we'll it will create
nothing but a land of square pegs and
square holes it's nonsense i mean
really what it comes down to is it shows
what education public education
specifically in this country is man it's
it's it's it's an indoctrination camp it
has nothing to do with education has
nothing to do with improving the
intellectual capacity of our next
generations in fact i'd argue that they
are putting obedience ahead of education
all they want to do is herd these people
into classes and indoctrinate them
politically on what they should think
they don't teach people how to think
anymore which is really all ap classes
do ap classes now you're talking about
logic now you're talking about
philosophy now you're talking about they
offered yeah opportunities did you take
ap i did you took ap yes okay so okay
i'm assuming you not all not all well
you don't take connors and ap classes
here's the difference all right in
regular history class
they teach you what happened
in ap history they ask you why it
happened and that is the difference
that's the major difference okay the
major difference is this is what
happened on these dates regurgitate this
get it get it right on the test so our
school can get money from the state
there you go in ap
it's you're already graded on a higher
curve you can have a 5.0 instead of a
4.0 so a b student in ap is still a 4.0
student okay so they already get the
money from the state and it's a small
amount of students that you don't get
into this is that that other side of the
bell curve
but they ask you these are the people
that they start asking questions why
okay and then i feel like in this
environment not to be crazy conspiracy
theory
these people do not want kids learning
how to ask the question why
they do not want a generation of people
asking why this is happening why we're
doing things this way they want people
that understand obedience above all else
well this is just the new york city
it's not obvious it's not though it's
it's the first time
it's the start it's the first domino to
fall i mean everything's going to do the
same thing you think other school
systems across the country are going to
implement this in math how about this
the fact that harvard was caught
by having completely different uh
admission standards
predicated on your nationality yeah
asian kids white kids and then everybody
else after that right where that you had
you had to score so remarkably higher
than other people to get in all right
the social stratification man like i i
again it goes back to everything that
we're talking about and also on a side
note bill de blasio first mayor in 100
years to not have a professional sports
team win a championship in new york city
i don't think that that is look it it's
an interesting coincidence but it goes
again like excellence is not something
that they want and it's amazing that
whenever we're talking about equality
whenever we're talking about inclusion
it's never about lifting people up it's
always about ripping people down of
course they're trying to get everybody
to instead of okay
easiest way to put it we want you all to
blend in with each other instead of
stand out
you're supposed to have standouts so
what you're saying is to encourage these
people fan their flames push them push
them push them because you don't want to
be the stumble bum is what we would say
back in you know my day you know
which means like you're going to be one
on the corner doing stupid [ __ ] well pal
i mean you definitely got to focus on
these things because it's very
imperative that and what about the kids
that want to excel
and get college credit while they're in
high school my younger brother did that
he was phi theta kappa at 16 years old
so he was exceptional right who's
pushing for this well should there be
varsity sports i mean what's the next
logical kick right everyone just should
there be varsity sports you just get the
nerd getting pummeled by gerrard in high
school that's funny but i'm just saying
varsity is ap sports
right right i mean what's why why if
we're if everything is going to be
exactly the same then why isn't
everything exactly the same
why is it only about these these this is
where my spidey senses start to tingle
why is it only about dumbing down and
indoctrinating the future that's when i
start to say man is this an effective
strategy is this an effective strategy
though so let's just say that is your
outcome let's just say that's your
outcome and you're trying to dumb him
down
do you think okay so do you think the
guy that's going to make it out is going
to make it out do you think the guy
that's going to be a standout is going
to be a standout he can't do nothing to
him i think that their argument their
argument is that we're not going to
divert the resources to a small section
of people we're going to give those
resources to everybody now but i'm not
asking you that what i'm asking you is
do you think the guy
that's gonna make it is gonna make it
whether they do this or not i think
what's gonna happen is
twofold you're gonna have people like
adam said that are so bored in these
classes that they check out and you're
gonna have people that the conversation
is so high above them that they check
out so i think that you're going to have
an opportunity really for khan academy
or some secondary educational school
where auto diadex are going to have to
work for autodidact although autodiatics
people that are studying on their own
they're self-taught they're
self-educated they're going to have to
seek out their own their own path yeah
and it's going to happen on both ends
you know i got a buddy of mine jamie
mcdermott one of my one of my best
friends in the world he was never dumb
but he was always misinterested he was
just disinterested in school just
disinterested never wanted to do
anything all he wanted to do was talk to
chicks the whole time if it wasn't for
sports he would have never gone to class
at all then he he goes to college and
something clicks and he's like you know
what man i got to get my [ __ ] together
now the dude's got an mba and he works
at fitch like he's crushing it but
similar to yourself if he had a 2.0 gpa
in high school it was a lot like he just
didn't care you know what i'm saying so
in this environment pushing him along
might work for a guy like jay because he
doesn't get left behind but in these and
correct me if i'm wrong every class is
different like i said i went i was in
dumb math but in smart history what have
you
everyone excels at different things like
you like you're talking were you good in
math was math math was not i was good up
until a certain point then when you
started throwing trigonometry and
geometry i'm like i'm out this is this
is did you use math analysis
uh i don't recall if i took that i i
crushed it normal stuff like addition
subtraction multiplication and then when
they started throwing x into
i was always like the class clown i was
like you know we're never gonna use this
[ __ ] like i was that kid in the
background like why are we doing this
make sense can i just go like play
football but the point is that some
people excel in certain classes some
people don't
so
if you're going to put everyone in the
same class same thing
like that
in itself
whether it's sports whether it's uh
woodshop all right we're all doing it
whoever does you know
but in each class each subject to put
everyone they have a heart and the same
thing makes sense teacher was more
important than the curriculum the
teacher if the teacher made it
interesting if the teacher made it
you know
the material engaging
then everybody was involved like like
whether or not we were good at math or
liked math it depended on the teacher i
had a teacher that made math into money
and baseball statistics and we were all
totally granted but then we had another
teacher who was like sit there shut up
and read the book so let's go back to it
let's go back to it so the question is
will this
do anything to the guy that's going to
make it anyways does this affect the
standout guy i think it does you think
so
you always hear these talented people we
always hear it in sports but it could be
in academics as well these talented
people that
did something went wrong i totally agree
with them i fully agree let me explain
to you i agree with you you guys you
guys know the story of nick boleteri you
know nick boleter the tennis coach yeah
the tennis coach yeah of course do you
know who he is like have you met him yes
yes he's in town in south florida yeah
he's in south florida he's the teacher
okay all my friends so let me tell you
who this guy is how do you describe him
his students
any of the students that went to his
camp how many champions how many grand
slams do you think they want all his
students
180 grand slam winners came out hundred
and eighty total grand slams he coached
these i think you're a family member
andre andre agassi was his phenom anyway
so there's a story there's a documentary
about this guy there's a documentary
about this guy where
he's uh coaching players right and he's
coaching jimmy connors and he's coaching
agassi and they're going back and forth
the story then goes to a story of two
girls that he was coaching
one of the girls is coming up and she's
crushing it she's kicking at 11 years
old she's gonna be the youngest you know
to go out and compete all the stuff
that's taking place with her and then
all of a sudden the father comes up and
the father says nick i want you to drop
everybody because the father was a very
very rich like billionaire and he says i
want you to drop everybody i just want
you to coach my daughter he's like i
can't do that i got a hundred kids here
it's not my business model he said i'll
pay you whatever you want he says you
don't understand that's not my business
mod he says i will pay how much you make
money i'm gonna make you dismiss i don't
want the money i want to coach the kids
anyways the pops gets pissed he says i'm
out of here. so he leaves the daughter
is telling this story the girl that
could have been she says when my dad
took me he says don't worry about it
we'll go find another coach they go to
another coach lower standards they go to
another coach low stand their dad kept
telling their daughter don't worry about
it this guy's good for you this guy's
good for you this guy's good for the
girls like i eventually became a nobody
if i would have stayed with nick i would
have been the top three right and the
whole story with nick is standards and
expectation high high standards and
expectation people rise up agassi
courier sellers
uh what he called the the sisters all of
those guys went through him right
what's the moral of the story here drop
the standards i believe that 12
to me it goes back to the same thing the
that has what it takes to dominate but
they don't get the right challenge
they're not pushed they're not
challenged to do more somebody's not
tough on it with the expectations high
you're going to lose that 12 percent so
i think this actually affects i agree
those guys i fully believe teachers
matter coaches i don't think it's just
teachers because remember even nick
wasn't the one that was teaching
everybody nick had 40 teachers that were
teaching putting together a program i
think it's a system of standards yes i
think it's a set of standards and
protocols when you have a certain set of
high expectations and standards one of
two things going to happen to you here's
what happens
you're either going to respond to it or
you're gonna hate this guy forever they
kept telling stories of two people two
guys and two girls agassi and jimmy
connors right agassi was his phenom
guess who's the only person that didn't
want to do an interview on this on this
documentary agassi is the only guy that
refused to do the interview all the
other people agreed to do it why
wouldn't i guess he did who didn't do
well with him is the people that hated
high standards agassi hated it and this
other girl hated it but jimmy connors
loved it so jimmy connors won eight
grand slams the uh the people that like
high standards like responded to it when
you have high standards and expectation
this is what you produce this is always
going to happen
what is the what is the most annoying
thing
about a great example
when it's right
what's the most annoying thing about
having a leader that's got a great
example
it's a great freaking example it sucks
it absolutely sucks because you're like
the hell with you so much pressure i
don't want to have to live up to this
expectation but what's the best thing
about having a guy like that he can push
you yep but regardless not everybody's
going to fit to those standards correct
you're still going to produce some
people that are going to be resenting it
and coming out and saying you know what
screw you i hate that teacher everybody
had that one coach that later on they
hated but deep down inside they're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
you know that guy really had he had
really challenged me we all have that
right i think this is a uh this is a
travesty what they're doing to the kids
there because there could be a few
phenoms that we're going to find out
about 10 20 30 40 years from now that
we're probably going to lose but i still
think that there's a small percentage of
people put them at one percent two
percent small percentage they're going
to figure out a way to kill what the law
the law of unintended consequences
something all these comedies refuse to
admit exists man
all it's going to take now is that
wealthy people or even middle class
people are going to put their kids in
into private school where you could have
had your kids
communicating networking learning from
these other people who were gifted and
then rise picking each other up like
you're talking about now what you're
going to have is you're going to have
this again this for social
stratification this segregation where
it's like i can't have my kid in the
school i can't have my kids in the world
people are already putting their kids in
private new york
but part of the reason why that you but
but again we're thinking well you're not
wealthy you're not from a wealthy family
but you're thinking i got a scholarship
no no no no no of course what i'm trying
to say is i don't want to lose you but
you're you're the one i don't want to
lose the guy that is a phenom the guy
that is a guy that needs somebody to
challenge him because he'll respond to
it in manhattan they've already been in
private schools but in queens they they
haven't been in staten island they
haven't been in in brooklyn a lot of
parts of brooklyn they're not you got
lincoln lafayette you got some i mean
you you this is the first this is what
you see
like has anybody ever tried to implement
well what happens is they they
what they tried to do which was probably
wrong in the other direction is that
they had like gifted schools where they
took the entire like gifted student
and then they put them in in gifted
schools which probably wasn't right in
its own right right but i just look i
just
on an overall level and there's somebody
that that you know is way more in depth
uh waiting for superman was it was a
phenomenal documentary
superman yeah you heard about what
happened to superman yesterday yes i did
yes uh superman's son is uh
is bisexual yeah yeah i mean good good
for him i didn't see him and and i'm
more super i'm more concerned with dc
making social media yesterday yeah i
decided this morning actually what do
you guys what do you think about the
collection
david let me ask superman's dc comics
coming out
the next superman's son is a bisexual
superman that's coming up soon he's
bisexual like in the comic world like a
bisexual socialist no no a real superman
son yeah in the comic world
i don't know like if you're talking
about dean kane or whoever
what do you think about that
i think it's lazy it doesn't bother me
that he's bisexual it doesn't bother me
it bothers me socialist but i mean it
doesn't bother me as bisexual
i don't know i can tell you the uh
look
i know i know people are bisexual i know
people that are gay if they feel somehow
edified by this good for them i just
think it's lazy why not make your own
superhero make your own story the
constant retconning of these you know
cultural icons and listen
they are doing it on purpose so when
they act like how are you getting mad
because you wanted people to get mad
superman's a jesus allegory superman was
a way to sell jesus to a new sense of
kid he's he's jesus if you look at the
uh if you look at jack snyder's um
uh bat superman right i mean he
literally has him being resurrected with
his feet crossed in his arms it it's a
jesus allegory it's the most obvious
jesus already since the matrix right so
i mean the fact that they know this and
then they went out of their way in the
press conference the way they were like
we just
we knew having another white male
straight white male savior
uh would have been a missed opportunity
and it's like okay so then you did it on
purpose like but he's not gay he's
bisexual apparently no no so the picture
why don't you pull it up to see the
picture i mean
his job is how is he not already you
tell kai to type
[Laughter]
[Music]
i gotta see this picture because i i
gotta go to images there it is right
there this freaking guy there it is okay
let me say something
i i know women
that are bisexual meaning they're into
dudes they're the chicks
i don't know any dudes that are bisexual
if you're asking some d
you're gay
that's it
there's no
there's no middle ground well you know i
from time to time i'll jerk a guy off
but
no i think i'm gonna go out no it's it's
done i'm sorry you do that i know i'm in
the chicks that's it oh i thought you
said from time to time
i'm just i'm i'm i'm putting my foot
down if you're gay god bless you all
good i've got gay friends
11 years from now 11 years again i know
a lot of gay people they're cool
miami beach south beach they're
everywhere i'm friends with them some of
my good friends are gay see them out all
the time say what's up yep i'm with none
of them
none of them are going home with girls
i'm with you on this girard
why be so lazy you could create a whole
new
series of different specifically to piss
people off they're doing it to piss
people off so i mean that's i i go from
not being pissed off to just do i care
yeah
who's the founder of dc comics no i
don't know who's who
is this a stanley project or no it's not
stanley
marvel so who's uh who's the dc comics
frank miller is the big is the video
performance frank miller is the
uh go to dc comics right there wikipedia
go to the bottom yeah just type on
let's see who it is so malcolm wheeler
um
so 87 years ago founded by the city of
national general malcolm wheeler uh go
coco malcolm wheeler
the black superman thing it's like a
little orchestra
no at all but would it
it's just lazy like just so if i was a
black superman you know i'm just playing
you kind of are you're as close to
superman as it gets thank you yeah dude
can't fly yet huh just can't fly yet a
little higher
x-ray vision have you tried you got to
make the leap bro
like the matrix bro you got to make the
leap
i don't know man it doesn't just feel
lazy isn't it i just feel like saying
this
trying too hard to sell you something
something like it's like i don't know we
get to sell the gay people
i think the guy that we had on from
facebook who is part of the lgbtq
community
he himself said that uh on facebook
they're trying really hard
to influence young kids to be part of
the community so
you know if that is the strategy let's
just say that's the strategy and where
the marketing from they hired great
strategy good for you he didn't like
that right he did not like that even
though he's part he is himself a part of
it he doesn't like the fact that you're
trying to manipulate kids yeah and so
gatsaad the godfather you know when he
and i uh we're both we got to get them
on here we got to figure out a day to
get them out parasitic yes
when i had them on and we were talking
about the whole lgbt test do you think
the tv shows and everything is
influencing kids to become a part of the
community says not at all i said well
let's look at some stats so we went to
the stats last 30 40 years and you can
tell 34 20 years ago was one percent
lgbt today's five percent that was
literally what i wanted to find out
you're saying five percent in the last
20 years yeah in the last 20 years it's
increased from one to five percent falls
under the lgbtq by the way
they've added new letters
yeah they've got to stop at p though i
think we can all agree on that b l b g b
t b whatever
i'm not even like like guy pull up lgbt
like there's three new letters right
there
abcd is 26 letters yeah what else
i think pb p lgbt pbb yeah
there's a q i a plus in there there it
is you're right you're right you're
right let's begin by say transgender uh
q i a what does lg get click on that
uh vicente transgender
[Music]
click on that one uh okay lesbian gay
bisexual transgender questioning queer
intersex pansexual
all right this is too much i'm confused
and dude respect to all you guys but
like if i'm a gay person
now i got to be
in between everything and i'm telling
you right now didn't dave chapel do a
joke about this you want to be with a
consenting adult
with the children is where that [ __ ] is
a hard line yes where hard where kevin
spacey came out and they were like hey
man are you with a 15 year old dude he's
like you know what you're right i decide
to live my life outwardly as a gay man
and the whole world was like
cool cool but what about the 15th yeah
exactly like that's that's all we're
talking about here man what about the
headquarters the drag stuff at night no
you know with the kids no no no it's
hard no live your life listen age you
know love age does matter age you know
age doesn't matter
yeah it does it let's just it does
i mean come on man you look whatever you
do with a consenting adult god bless by
the way god bless you i just had i just
had i agree one what was his name juan
pablo valdez is am i saying jorge pablo
valdez which from 77 to 80 he was the
number one cocaine dealer in the world
okay jorge luis jorge luis valdez jorge
luis valdez from cuba
that moves to miami
gets his degree then one of his clients
that's a market that they have every
month he's depositing 500 thousand
dollars saying how do you have this kind
of money he says listen we don't do this
kind of stuff this is just you know
stuff that we have to hide we have a
cocaine business and back then you know
he was killing it he made like 60
million dollars he's 21 years old
cooking cowboys has a documentary about
the guy so i said what was it like being
in cuba he says in cuba he says you know
you couldn't believe in god
you could not believe in god why
couldn't you believe in god
you know the whole concept of communism
you can't believe in god state is god
the state is god the whole concept with
hitler was what you cannot believe in
god
it's it's who it's i am your god right
hitler is your god and dietrich
bonhoeffer uh wrote about this you know
probably the story of dietrich
bonhoeffer it's a great story kai that's
another book you got to wrap up with
dietrich bonhoeffer
so this guy stood up to hitler and
hitler couldn't stand this guy and what
he was doing
the moment you if you really want to
control the populace the first thing
that's got to go is believing in a
higher power
the moment you get rid of that
you don't believe you can go fight a
bigger opponent okay and this book naked
communist written by cleon skousen which
was a 15-year
cia agent and he wrote about a certain
steps one of them was indoctrination of
the
lgbtq overly listen we all know somebody
that's gay in the family everybody has
somebody you're like yeah listen i've
known since you were i don't know
you've been like this for a long time so
it's not like it's you know it's like
hey what's up it's cool no problem right
everything's fine but the overly of
trying to get you to question those
thoughts of how do you know maybe what
if not what if this
you're starting to see some of those
things one of the things is faith get
people to stop believing in god because
once faith is gone people don't believe
they can fight against the system this
is the other one there's a lot of
different things that they're going
through as well everybody's equal
there's like 25 steps they're going
through gradually this is taking place
last night we're having dinner we were
at the casa d'angelo and angelo showed
up which was very nice and he made the
elk uh would you you had the bison last
night yeah who had the yellow couple
people had elk did you also have elk no
i had the uh the zoo but i gave you a
little bit of this
really sick
so anyways so we're there we're talking
about all this stuff and the
conversation with our friend that was
there who you know got really
interesting at the end we talked about
briefly about this but this one the
topics i brought up and i had my
research and pulled things up i'm
curious
you know about this i'm going to ask kai
and the other guys
you don't get to say anything to the
very end okay because we talked about
this i want to see what this guy's going
to say i'm convinced
and you tell me if you agree with us or
not kai you too david youtube i'm
convinced we
are born conservative or liberal
i'm convinced you're born
left or right
i'm convinced you're born with left
tendencies or right tendencies
i believe a majority of the population
is born on those two sides let me
explain i'll give you my argument and
please trash the argument and folks i
want you to trash this argument as well
as we're going through tell me if you
agree with us or not
so for example i had a friend of mine
who married a girl who was a full-on
socialist we go to dinner together
and i'm listening to her i couldn't
understand like she was
out of this world completely like aoc's
the greatest all this stuff rich people
are this capitalism sucks all they care
about is money non-stop she's going
and i pause this can i ask you a
question she said yeah
i said what was your favorite subject in
high school she said uh art
i said what else
journalism what else
music
how do you feel about
math oh i hate math
really why do you hate math i just i've
never liked math it always came hard to
me and from the moment i started taking
that it made me feel like i'm dumb it
made me feel like i'm not smart i've
just never liked math
got it
for the last 10 years i've been asking
people this question who's on the left
who's on the right how they are with
math it's not always right but about
seventy percent of time eighty percent
of the time
it's right you'll notice most people
that our right brain will lean left a
lot of people that are left brain
will lean right right but then there is
a small populace okay which is
like you know in america today there's a
percentage of americans you cannot make
them vote right there's nothing you can
do about it it's about 44 right
you can say whatever you want to say
they're not going to vote republican
okay
there's 42 percent that no matter what
you say to them they're not going to
vote democrat that's just kind of what
you're dealing with then you got a
little bit of the the whole thing we
talked about with uh what do you call a
libertarian libertarian independent give
those four five you're really dealing
with what 10 or 12 percent right
i think 12
of america
kids are born not just america kids are
born 12 kids are born and those are the
ones that are kind of like
huh i kind of see what you're saying
that's a good point let me see what he
has to say you know what gerard you made
a good point phil you know i don't know
i agree with him now but gerard he just
said something huh let me kind of weigh
this out they're malleable i think
there's about 12 percent that's
malleable okay
if you are able to whoever converts that
12 the best that party wins so this
isn't about fighting somebody that's
never going to swa a switch
left or right this is about finding that
12 of reasonable people that are willing
to sit there and say here's my argument
what do you think well pat what do you
think i read one time in the article
said this well here's what i think about
this why i disagree with you cool let's
go back and forth banter i'm convinced
people are born left and people are born
right and the goal is to find that 12
percent that's malleable that you can
shift their thinking and let them have
that debate to make a decision for
themselves what are your thoughts real
quick how many of those 40
on either side
believe they're in that 12 percent from
hearing this
how many
how many to 40 how many of the 40
percent unswayable on either side oh
they know listening to this no they
don't no no they know vince they're in
that room let me put it to you this way
the group that knows they're not is a
group that says pat has no clue what the
hell he's talking about but there's a
group that's listening to this that's
saying
i can't say this to anybody i can't
admit to it definitely i cannot admit to
anybody but i got to tell you lately
i've been kind of questioning some of
this [ __ ] it's like not making any sense
why the hell would you get rid of you
know ap and honors program tell me how
that makes any sense why the hell would
you fire this person why the hell would
you want to do this to taxes and change
the incentives why the hell would you
want to give people money to non-stop i
saw how my dad did that to my sister my
sisters now this yeah i don't know if
i'm stuff is starting to make sense to
me like believe me the 12
of the populace is already questioning
it on both sides they're sitting there
questioning it on both sides challenges
to be able to convert them so if this is
true let's just say if this is true yeah
if this is true you know what this means
88 of arguments are worthless
[Laughter]
i do believe that
88 percent of the debates are awarded
did you understand what i said if this
is correct so protect your energy big
time yeah 88 is a waste of time are you
saying this is exclusive in america or
no no worldwide no i think this is this
is worldwide and you're saying born
i think you're born like how you say
you're born gay you're born straight
there's nothing no you know what it is
nature versus nurture you're saying this
is something greatly i'm not saying i'm
giving an example you're saying yeah i
think so you're saying you're born
politically laughter politically right
yes
i
i'm not buying it yeah i mean listen i
knew you weren't gonna buy it i know
well i'll tell you why i knew you
weren't gonna buy it like recently i had
a conversation that's what i was asking
the united states worldwide like so for
instance my sister yeah loves trump okay
loves trump
same
fair parent same dad same mom loves
trump she couldn't tell you one point
she's gonna lose her job for love and
trump or she's gonna be okay this [ __ ]
hasn't worked in years married to a
wealthy dentist damn yeah i said it
um
bro
she's uh
yeah
sounds like adam he's just making sure
she's all right
what's funny
she's like a is
dictator thank you um that just her
husband is a wealthy dentist awesome
anyway we're on fire today
i promise you he loves you i promise you
keep going
i do love my sister do i like her and
we'll see um
but she loves don't you talk about it
yeah let's let's bring it up let's go a
10-minute dive tribe my family break a
couch here let this guy lay down for him
that's right that's gerard
um
so another conversation i had recently
was with a friend of mine from israel
yeah and they were obviously you see a
lot of results that are happening with
the vaccine not to get too vaccinated
right now
but i said who's hesitant in israel
taking the vaccine
and they go oh no it's uh it's uh
it's the people on the left
i said what
they go yeah yeah the people on the way
left they don't they don't they don't
want to do anything with the vaccine i
said hold on let me get this straight
because traditionally in the united
states it's
not traditionally like we've seen
a lot of young male
skewing right
do not want to take the vaccine a lot of
african-americans will take it as well
what happens to me the way it's been
sure all right and then so they flipped
it on me they were like yeah you know
it's the people on the left highly
educated
um
just
factors that you did not expect to hear
highly educated people here too actually
questionably no no um quantifiably we
did it three podcasts so phds the um
so it wasn't a left
red button like it flipped it so the
point is this
i'm not i'm not understanding like
depending on where you're born
depending on what country you're in
i i think politics is completely
different i don't think just because you
were born in the united states that
you're automatically going to be on the
left or the right so let me let me let's
understand why so here's the question
let me go a little bit later deeper okay
you ever seen a family same mom and dad
four kids
one becomes a phenom crushes it
one just a regular government employee
one becomes a drug addict and one
becomes a priest you ever notice like
what the hell just happened same mom and
dad same environment same upbringing
four different human beings yeah yeah
yeah i think there's a part of your dna
where you're wired in a certain way and
a big part of it is politically because
because so don't get me wrong i have
these other four issues that i add to it
i made a video about this four years ago
i think it has to do with your
upbringing and i think it has to do with
your family i think it has to with your
first person that took a liking into you
and gave you a lot of love and you feel
like there's a certain level of loyalty
to that person whether that person's a
left or right or rich or poor or
whatever it is you kind of have that
loyalty to that person a person early on
that was an influencer that you started
reading up on you're like oh my gosh i
believe in this guy's philosophy i think
all that stuff has also placed it and
then i think it also has to do with if
you had a bad experience with gun when
you were you know 16 years old one of
your little nephews or you know nieces
saw a gun that left it their shot
themselves you're probably never going
to lie this is all stuff that happens
while growing up though sure
i agree i agree but i still think
there's a part of people where your
wiring is to be once said because there
is no way a guy on the left and a guy on
the right
smart both on both sides they're smart
on both sides you know left things the
rights dummies and the right things the
people on the left are down neither one
of them are dumb then what is it with
them because they're both very convicted
in their beliefs how did that happen
it's what they prioritize so
you know the
i i tend to agree with you but i also
tend to agree with adam i don't think
it's a left and right issue because
politics are constantly evolving i do
think that there's a proclivity to
either value intellect or emotion i
think that some people don't care
whether or not you're right as long as
you make somebody feel good you
understand like there's some people that
are like i don't care if i'm right as
long as that person feels good and
comfortable with me and then there's
other people that are like if that
person can't be comfortable with the
truth to hell with them right and that's
that's you that's definitely me right
yeah you can ask the the
truth that was just written about peter
thiel contrarian right that guy you keep
talking about you know maybe maybe it's
conform and non-conform
maybe it's it's agree and disagree maybe
it's
question and don't question maybe it's
that but to me there isn't element of
some people that just say oh yeah yeah
some people have to be like yeah they
have to yeah some people are just kind
of like but you know there's a part of
that again look at the creative side
though
creative is typically
hollywood is creative left you look at
how the creative typically leans left
you look at the logic typically leans
right you know what you say about the
country singers there are a lot of them
that are right and they're all creative
good point
country singers that are what that are
on the right yeah then then that goes to
how they're raised and that goes to
their upbringing that goes to you know
their rituals and their values for the
country and what they saw that goes to
that part as well but that's a very
small genre of the the industry remember
i'm not saying this is a hundred percent
i'm saying 70
i feel like
politics is almost like religion i was
born into a jewish family you know we
were doing jewish practices customs and
traditions if i happen to be uh you know
my dad is a percentage italian and for
whatever reason he married an italian
woman i would have born into a catholic
family and i would have been a catholic
and i agree like
religion more than anything it's
around you know what you're raised
around and that's what you're going to
be if i was true but think about this
more validates my point this more
validates my point what percentage am i
talking about ten percent right
ninety percent of people if your dad's a
christian you're a christian if your mom
is a catholic you're a catholic but
there's a 10 that's kind of like i have
to figure this out for myself you think
it's only 10 that seems so that seems so
low i don't i think it's that small of a
percentage
i think it's that small of a percentage
the predator theory is 80 20 whether
it's 10 or 20 it's not a big number i'm
telling you right now it is not a big
number mo go back to your classroom and
think about who was like okay yeah okay
yeah okay yeah and i think about some of
the guys are like well how about this
how about if we try this come over this
what about that why do we do this why
did this take place what about that what
about this there is the white person i
want to know more tell me give me some
depth in this right so that it's not a
big deal how do you have massive
cultural changes like how does how does
uh slavery end if that's the case how do
how do things evolve how does it end
yeah because somebody questioned it so
one of that ten percent
one of that ten percent comes out of
course and then the they they are able
to convert well go back and go back more
like ten percent go back to our meaning
go back to genocides go back to any of
these events that took place man like
when you're in it you don't even know
when you're in it you're thinking there
is no out
but there is a 10
small percentage that has faith that
this can change and they're willing to
stand up
slavery stopped because of who does that
10 what happened let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question let me ask you a
question this is not no conspiracy
theory it's just a question i'm about to
ask you okay so don't flip out here
folks who are you know this is just the
question
the cause of lincoln's death
the doctor
abraham lincoln
the cause of lincoln's dead you know at
the fourth theater everyone's been there
you've seen okay
what was it cause is it just a black and
white cause
no it's a series of events okay so the
the the
the security guard leaving his post you
know john wilkes booth obviously the
conspiracy shooting and then a lot of
people think that lincoln could have
somehow survived that the doctor might
have actually accelerated his death too
so well
okay fine let's go put a percentage on
it you think people like the fact that
he stood up as a republican against uh
those who liked slavery no literally
half the nation left okay so that's the
point there look at this guy who's a
president who could have easily said
yeah let's just go one more i'm not
going to be the guy let grant be the one
that fights for something like this this
guy stood up for it how many people
would have done that not a lot of people
most people passed the buck right that's
a 10 community the 10 community is not
believe it or not it's the 10 percent
that has the courage to stand up and
talk about stuff that others don't want
to talk but what happened last night
when we're talking to this guy i want to
say his name because that's his business
what did he say i just you know i
lived in california you saw where he was
living in california and you know we
were talking
politics
you know biden's you know flips out luke
all of a sudden he went from zero to
pissed off he was like this the entire
time yep composure the next thing you
know boom right and we're like and you
live in california yeah
dude what the hell just happened right
now the last costume is business flips
out cost him his business of course the
cosmos business but guess what he says
yeah i don't want to do the social media
stuff because they come after you that's
yep that's 90 percent because who the
hell wants that he's going to have to
pass the buck i'ma pass the buck you try
to do no no i'm going to pass the buck
now i'm going to pass the ball you don't
want the pressure i think
the 10
of people who have the audacity to
question are the ones that are going to
say man this goes all the way back to
our initial conversation about the kids
you start reducing that percentage
you get
the least amount of leaders that
actually want to speak up and speak out
and do [ __ ]
there's by the way there's nothing like
like look right now i'm the host of this
show i'm presenting this you guys are
disagreeing i'm not offended this is how
it's supposed to be this is how we're
learning this is how we go back and
forth then i'm finding leaks in my
argument and saying well like i got a
bunch of papers sitting on my desk to go
look at this is how this course takes
place right well you get better this is
how it is with the kids as well this is
a conversation but i think the 10
percenters
are gonna like us i don't think the 90
the audience likes us to be honest with
you i think i think if you're part of 90
community i guys said this the other day
on twitter he tweeted this i don't know
if you guys saw this or not
he said something to me the other day
and i retweeted and i responded to him
he said you know i don't know what to
make of you pat oh
did you see that says i don't know what
to make of you i saw that he says uh
uh he says uh you know one minute you're
this and one minute your dad i don't
even know if i have it maybe i okay
there it is he says patrick i really
don't know what to do with you i just
can't categorize you which is
frustrating you're like a moving target
that is very difficult to hit one moment
you're fantastic the next moment you're
very disappointed i'm at my wits
with you right and i respond i said
there will be more changes coming soon
so save yourself to frustration and
agony and move on it doesn't sound
healthy for you i wish you nothing but
the very best you know why you know why
because we're questioning yeah and we're
like trying to get a little bit more to
say well you know what i don't know you
know just put it together to define you
they want to box you in they want to say
oh no this is him and this is what oh
hold on what what that that doesn't add
up adam it's more blows their mind it's
more than that they they don't they
don't want to hear what you have to say
they want to hear you saying what they
want oh yeah remember they want to speak
to an echo champion you actually made a
great point before about the
intersection between politics and
religion that is
where we're at right now so when you
can't have an intellectual conversation
with something that's so emotional right
normally it would be or or the way it
was supposed to be politics were
intellectual right it's a discussion
about how to allocate resources in
government right there there's always a
sliding scale there's sometimes we need
more there's sometimes we need less and
it should always be over discussion
right
religion is is for people it's eternal
it's the eternal truth this is i am
right everybody else is wrong and i'm
betting my eternal soul on it right so
there is there there's this idea of of
when you question someone's religion
you're questioning their entire identity
you're not questioning their
decision-making in the moment you're
questioning who they are as a person so
as people have taken their politics and
they've taken their political
perspective as their religion as their
worldview and as their personality you
can't disagree with them politically
because now you're disagreeing with the
essence of their themselves you're
saying you're a bad person you don't
understand and that's that's a really
really dangerous place to be i want to
give a couple shout outs here for
comments that people made super chatters
so we got
sandy butler on i'm sorry smedley
butler iii pat you asked your crew a few
days ago about the new world order i've
also heard you mentioned numerous times
china being our number one enemy but
what if there's an even bigger enemy and
even greater threat to our lives and
freedom so
smedley i appreciate that and i'm
reading a few books on that topic right
now maybe we'll have a follow-up on it
and then 50
journey yeah we did a how-to on that
topic yeah yeah today today's video how
to is actually uh
biggest threats to america but anyways
pbd i agree children are born with no
left or right until they encounter an
influence if you have children without
any sway without parents in a bubble
they will naturally flow one way or
another without prejudice i agree i'm
leaning towards what he's saying as well
so you know 50 thanks for that and we
had chico lopez commented about uh
chico lopez gave me a uh heavyweight
belt a couple years ago oh man that
dealt the chief was freaking obese and
chico's trying to give me a dog by the
way he said bring tyson fury he was bred
to be a world champion he's a top dog
and a friend
uh he is getting uh a litter made puppy
to yours he is awesome never give up
going to london chico why don't you set
that up and let's get uh tyson here we'd
love to have him uh did you guys end up
watching if i don't know did you watch
you didn't watch that none of you guys
watched it did you watch the fight
one of the sickest fights ever crazy
crazy sickest fights i've ever seen
people are giving deontay wilder crap
for not being a good sportsman dude just
took a beating yeah yeah what do you
want him to do he didn't know where he
was like
do you think he's done deontay
psychologically he's done it's a tough
one man i i don't i don't think he's
done per se because that right hand
should have knocked out fury multiple
times if anything he's probably sitting
here like what what's going on have i
lost my powers like i don't i don't see
anthony joshua beating deontay wilder i
just don't know do you want to watch it
i don't i don't because we're trying
we're trying to figure out like what's
the next fight i think i i think if old
check and and uh and uh fury could be
good
that's david and goliath and by the way
that's fine to see that but i tell you
if he doesn't beat fury he's
psychologically done diante wilder if
you're listening to this there's one
fight to make it i don't think that it
is logan paul dante
i don't know can we even need to be
mentioning diana wilde's
it has to be all about tyson fury this
guy is by far and away the number one
heavyweight he's making boxing without
freaking tyson fury doing what he do
we'd be talking about by the way many
agree over here many agreements
okay forget about dante wilder i don't
care if he stays boxing he's done he's
not fighting fury anymore he's beat his
ass three times did you replace tom
center
you sound like a guy named tom center
is always wrong speaking of conspiracy
there daniel cormier who i love did you
hear him talk about how deontay actually
knocked out uh fury that was a
crate andre ward and daniel cormier
going back and forth on twitter talking
about how long
the uh the standing eight count fury got
on the second knockout what knockdown
was i was like i don't know yeah by the
way you know the dustin portia interview
is going uh uh being picked up all over
espn reached that was espn reached out
to us yesterday they reached out because
they're gonna use like 32nd of the clip
because a couple comments he made he
said that the biggest puncher was who
connor he said doesn't matter what year
was he was the biggest puncher he said
khabib he says you don't even know what
to do with that guy with khabib and then
when i asked him the question who would
replace the dana white if dana won they
wanted to step away i said can you see
connor doing that he says no i can't see
connor doing this but i can see daniel
cormier he gave daniel some love you
know for replacing smart guy yeah
yeah can you like dc running ufc i can't
see it that's pretty silly but dana
white's not going anywhere not any time
not anytime
dc in the in the booth though i want to
i want conor mcgregor does connor ever
want to step out and want to fight yeah
does conor ever fight against he's
partying a little too much man his post
yesterday yeah i don't i don't know he's
injured but he's an athlete through and
through he'll come back yeah come on
like yeah connor will come back take a
couple years be confident listen it's
really hard to get up and put in the
miles when you're when you're waking up
sat in sheets right pajamas
i'm calling conor mcgregor out right now
you want to come back
david
david give it to me
give it to me all right let's go
southwest airlines story there's your
sports uh section that we had uh page
five uh southwest airlines folks if
you're thinking about flying southwest
you may want to skip it well it's not
just southwest
so southwest airlines
canceled 1800 flights this weekend a
morning brew story southwest airlines
weekend was as chaotic as its
boarding process it canceled over 800
flights on saturday more than a thousand
on sunday representing 28 of all flights
scheduled for sunday they blamed air
traffic control issues a staffing
shortage and a disruptive weather but no
other airlines seem to have those
problems the ffa
said in a statement that yeah there were
a few hours of delay due to staffing
issues in jacksonville florida but that
has been resolved friday what could be
contributing to the cancellation
southwest runs a point-to-point route
network where a single delay can create
an avalanche of other flight disruptions
but they're not touching on the real
issue i think 30 percent of employees at
southwest are not vaccinated and they're
being forced to work and they're not
wanting to
which means as of today uh one of the uh
airline pilots was being interviewed
yesterday says what would typically take
two days to arrive for amazon now it's
going to be three or four days so
there's going to be some kind of effect
to it but who's actually looked into
this have you actually looked into this
or not have you spent yeah thanks to a
big fan of the show and a guy who's
running for congress up in uh a former
director uh from l.a who's running for
congress in tennessee named robbie
starbuck he's he's been uh doing some
unbelievable work on this and they're
calling it by the way he's a stud great
last name if you want some sponsors
they're calling it the freedom flu the
freedom flew so uh as of according to mr
starbuck as of this morning 200 plus
northrop grumman employees called out
sick today and protested in front of
northrop grumman uh this is this is how
it goes guys this is disobedience this
is how you take your power back if these
guys want to play their power games you
don't have to be powerless
you can get together but it only happens
apes together strong it only happens
like the the guy last night you're
talking about he's afraid to speak
because he feels like he's alone and
that is why you speak to find out you're
not alone all right you speak up when
you're right you're right right the the
we talked about it you know two podcasts
ago all it takes for evil to prevail is
for good men to do nothing if you know
in your bones that you're right and
you're standing on the right side of
history speak up all right be prepared
to have your career be killed on that
hill and you will be surprised you will
be shocked by how many of your fellow
humans and your neighbors are decent
people and they will stick up for you
but you gotta like kinda like pat was
saying before you gotta be that ten
percenter you gotta be that person
willing to step up and step out and
everybody else will come i'm telling you
everybody else will come to you adam i
mean i don't know about you guys this is
why i only fly private these days
this is enough of this
me and samwell all we do
is is fly private samuel and i um
i i think the ironic part here is and
i'm not sure if this genuinely has to do
with i think southwest pilots the union
sued southwest or the vaccine mandate
i don't know if that's what it is but
the ironic part is they're saying that
it was the disruptive weather that was
limiting you know why i know why they
said that no other
airlines were dealing with they said
that no other airlines were dealing with
bad weather why they say that these this
is these flights are cancelled for a
case of let's go brandon is that all
right but are southwest the only airline
that is is mandating vaccines is that
what it is no no
why they say it i'm not you you have a
point what is it i'm asking you why do
you think they they said
weather
well obviously it's not the weather so
they're looking for a scapegoat here so
i don't know what's the scapegoat
phil tell me something baby i'm just
saying man like i don't know i don't i
don't to be honest i fly private or
american i don't mess with southwest all
right so when it's weather you don't
have to pay
you don't have to take care of the
customers oh is that what it is think
about it anytime there's a weather delay
do you get reimbursed no they're like
we'll find another flight
ma and only if you have like certain
crazy status where you ever get a
voucher hotel or something after three
hours on the phone begging for it right
yeah was any other airline even remotely
close to the two thousand flights
canceled like does that cancel but there
were two hundred
flights that were delayed but that's
when they're saying this so it wasn't
this weekend no no so it was all it was
all bs the air traffic control there was
no air traffic controllers
they they shut it down shut it down
they just hey look the truckers the
truckers out in australia imagine what
will happen if this type of mentality
continues together strong baby
the
holidays may be
a little bit
darker winter than even fauci says
because you're not going to get your
toys on time you're not going to get
certain supplies on time hey the uh
the gw bridge is only two lanes
that would take two two truckers
to to to park their their uh their semis
on the on the uh oh yeah northbound and
the southbound side going into jersey
and going into new york get out and walk
and the whole bridge would be shut down
why do you have a smile on your face
while you're saying he's hoping it
happens it would take i would i would
never i would never wish that on my
worst enemy be stuck in gw traffic but
i'll tell you what you wanted to make a
point about
mandates and about we know where chris
christie gets his ideas from buddy now
we know where chris christie gets all
his brilliant ideas the only nutrition
tips that's that's it that's all i get
fantastic that seems to be working
fantastic john gruden john gruden
john gruden
let's do a light story
ain't that light no this is a light
story here guys john groon's a good
football coach okay
uh john gruden used racial trope to
describe nfl pa chief
uh the maurice uh smith in 2011 emailed
the wall street journal on july 21 2011
national football league and his players
were working to resolve the lockout that
threatened the upcoming season that they
the league owners voted to ratify a new
collective bargaining agreement but the
players opted not to vote on it
immediately citing outstanding issues
that the union was fighting to resolve
the same that same day john gruden the
current las vegas coach uh raider coach
who has been one of the most prominent
figures in the nfl over the past two
decades sent an email to demauria smith
the executive director of the nfl player
association to
a team executive gruden's email
described smith was a racist trope
common in anti-black imagery uh dumb uh
dumb dumbora smith has lips the size of
a michelin tires he wrote in the email
the nfl is reviewing gruden's status
with the raiders for potential
discipline yesterday the tweet comes out
and saying uh that adam shaffer i think
came out and said he is probably going
to step he's going to get fired and then
announcement was made that he resigned
yeah uh and john gruden is no longer the
head coach of
the raiders which they were off to a
decent start
uh and
there's a couple other stories that came
out as well but that's what i'm gonna
stop right here if you got any comments
adam i'm gonna start with you first
well
uh this really resonated with me when i
saw randy moss uh
weigh in on this over the weekend did
you see randy
break down in tears
look uh i think the nfl is 70 black
okay um
it's clear that
i don't know less than 20 of the nfl
coaches are black
i don't i think it's 10 of the gm or the
front office that are that are black
and this was just i'm not saying that
john groon's a racist i am saying that
he's a [ __ ] idiot
um
he completely lost
his locker room if if
what's al davis's son's name mark davis
okay they were known for the bad boys at
the nfl but this is not the bad boys
that you want to be
these days okay so he's lost the locker
room if 70 of your team is black how do
they even respect you at this point you
know what you're doing when you're
calling dumb morris smith
and using racist tropes like huge lips
or the size of michelin tires apparently
he was also using some anti-gay slurs
about michael sam the gay guy that was
um rams that was drafted by the rams he
was talking
major crap about roger goodell calling
him a p-u-s-s-y and an f-a g-g whatever
whatever um i'm sure he's the first
person ever that called gordon no i'm
sure well goodell gets hated on a lot
but
i think at the end of the day he was a
complete distraction and if he stayed on
his coach this is something that the
raiders would be dealing with all year
and i don't think it's a uh
i don't think it's ironic that they've
lost their last two games since this has
kind of been out in the in the news and
they lost to a
not that good of a bears team with a
rookie quarterback over the weekend he's
lost the team and he had to go
okay
listen um
we saw with brett kavanaugh listen
and in your interview with the facebook
moderator the fact that anybody can read
any message that's ever been on any
facebook platform whatsapp instagram uh
if we're all going to be adjudicated for
[ __ ] that we said 10 11 12 years ago
there's gonna be a lot of people that
got a lot to [ __ ] answer for boy let
me tell you all right and
i'll also say
and i'll be controversial okay
black people are not a protected species
you can't just say that
he said something that was can be
construed as racist and that's a career
death sentence all right especially in
in a league
where
[Music]
desean jackson said anti-semitic things
said anti-semitic things that were
i mean he he quoted a man who who quoted
hitler
he didn't lose his job in the league he
quoted fair economy yeah he didn't lose
his job in the league i mean i i think
that what john gruden did is stupid
inadvisable he thought that what he was
saying was private he was probably
trying to be edgy in a private
conversation also sent
uh naked photos of women and stuff like
that
it's a bad look it's a bad look for the
guy who's the ceo of the organization i
get all that but he should have never
apologized first of all because the
people that have a problem with this
stuff
they're never going to be like okay well
he apologized he's going to learn from
it no never freaking apologize that's
number one never backpedal if you
believe in your heart of hearts that
you're not actually racist if you
you're not actually misogynist and this
is just the language that you grew up in
the times that you grew up in then
explain it like that all right but as
soon as you back pedal as soon as you
apologize you give credence to your
accusations okay that's number one
number two if the nfl
is really has a problem
with
uh homophobic slurs
and misogyny
then how in god's name is snoop dogg
eminem and dr dre
the
halftime
a performance this year why'd you take
my [ __ ]
i'm just saying if you're so right if
you really have a problem and i love
eminem and i love dr dre and i love
snoop dogg's music okay but if this is
really an issue
then how are they your super bowl half
time there's a difference between a
performer who comes in for 15 minutes
just call it what it is
just say what it is i don't think that's
what it is i think if a black guy said
this about white people he'd be fired
too
desean jackson we literally just
shouldn't happen that's a one wide
receiver this is the face of your team
you have to leave you have to be coaches
are facing the team of the raiders for
sure they just they brought him out of
the announcing booth he hasn't coached
in 15 years okay and they made him
everything and everything for the
raiders so to your point it's not like
he's some scrub wide receiver that goes
from here
that guy's been on 12 teams in 12 years
right so you got gruden 10 years 100
million
they're like let's get them out of here
so we can save some money i don't know
three and two right is the record that
they currently have
look this is back in july
of 2011. this is [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] you're bringing up stuff
from like 10 years ago of this stuff
like if it was that damn serious people
do what they want to do
if you really thought this was an issue
you would have done something
then
what you should have done so roger
goodell all you people that were
involved
raise your hand and say i didn't really
care about it 10 years ago but i sure do
now and explain because we need an
explanation
because you know what if they pulled up
something from me 10 years ago
they say phil you thought this way i'd
be like yeah back then
but i don't do now and and no like at
the end of the day what gerard is saying
is right
you run a sports organization
okay when you have certain people
perform
at the biggest event pretty much in our
country which is the super bowl right
billions of dollars involved
and you have people
like eminem that have said the word
f-a-g-g-o-t plenty of times
and the stuff that snoop dogg has said
plenty of times
you got to call a spade a spade here it
is adam this is spade you're going to
call it or not because they are
representing your brand during that time
if they were
okay let me ask you this if r kelly
wasn't uh
you know behind bars would you and he
was uh supposed to do the super bowl
what were your thoughts would be
you say hell no he's not representing
the nfl this and that and the other but
you got these guys representing the
super bowl there you go eminem from 2012
ready i may fight for gay rights
especially if the dyke is more of a
knockout than janae rice play nice [ __ ]
i'll punch lana de rey in the face twice
like ray rice in broad daylight in plain
sight of elevator surveillance to the
head is banging on the railing then
celebrate with the ravens
[Music]
and what's name one thing and what team
does the eminem coach
he's performing for the entire season
let me let me hang on i'm trying to i'm
trying because there is a point here so
what you're saying is the comment
is irrelevant it's the stat status of
the individual making the comment is
what you're saying okay so you're saying
a player can get away with making any
comment at all and a rapper can get away
with it but not a head coach that's what
you're saying i did not say any comment
a player can't get away with any we saw
what happened with um
the guy on the heat
who said some
to luca manchester no no um what was the
the center uh miles uh he said something
anti-semitic right yeah i forget his
name what happened to him he was
released from the team he was injured
he's gone okay players can get it too
you gotta understand if you're the coach
of the team yeah nfl is very fickle if
it's if the sentiment of the team or if
the mood of the team sways a little bit
they're looking for heads to roll so i
got a few this is the coach of the team
i don't i'm saying this i think you make
a good point there and i think that's
something to process to say a leadership
person uh is held to another myers
leonard is the guy i'm thinking about
okay so now you're ready now you're
ready for this now you're ready for this
okay
when he said it was he a head coach
he was an announcer i believe that so
he's not so so he didn't he never made
that comment as a head coach he made
that comment as an announcer but wait
let's let's let's okay let's go through
each he made that comment as an
announcer working for who at the time he
was a former nfl coach who was no no he
was the
you don't think espn knew about that
i don't know maybe maybe they did
but wait a minute let's actually process
this you don't think espn knew about
that common mate 10 years ago
i don't know okay i don't want to
speculate and say yes or no
are you leaning more towards yes or no i
literally don't know what yes but if you
were to play odds vegas gambling are you
leaning towards yes or no i i'm not what
do you think do you think espn new
no okay you think espn knew
i don't think so just because i mean
where was the data located off of
someone's server or something yeah this
is an email this is a data lake this is
coming out because of uh sexual
harassment allegations within the uh
washington football team uh
there they've been
so you mean to tell me smith the guy he
sent the executive the email to you
think he's kept it a secret for 10 years
but he didn't he said
he sent it to bruce and he's kept it a
secret for 10 years maybe not okay i'm
not convinced espn didn't know you think
he has been new i'm i'm 55 percent
daniel and i i'm convinced espn is kind
of like look guys this cannot be
tarnished in espn we are a clean image
there's no way this can come out now
he's a head coach of the raiders 100
million dollar contract 60 million
guarantee all this other stuff screwed
you know let's now bring it out because
there's other stuff coming in throw that
email in there as well okay cool so so
people hang on to stuff for a long time
by the way just so you know this isn't
the first time that somebody's hanging
on to an email with somebody you push a
little bit too much and he made some bad
comments about biden and obama and some
enemies
can you go pull up what comments he made
about obama and biden but i'm going to
go to a different angle here i'm going
to go to a different so that's one area
i understand the coach think when you're
a coach you have to be careful with the
words what you're saying let me go to
the next part especially when seventy
percent of your players if not more
black when he made the comment he worked
for espn espn should have fired him if
they knew about it it's important to
mention this though and i do believe him
when he says this because in the email
he praised gene upshaw who is black if
he really meant demur
the maurice smith
uh as uh you know this was like a racial
over mine he he claims he meant it as a
lot of times this guy's lying right
and in the context
of the the context of the rest of the
email that makes sense he's talking
about him as a liar i have to state one
fact here how old do you think john
gruden is
50. do you want me to read 54. he's 58
years old he's 58 so these emails that
came out seven 10 years ago
he's a 50 year old man
okay making these dumb ass comments
talking to his friend i don't care who
he's talking to you're a head coach
you're a face of the nfl it's not like
he's 18 like if someone's 16 18 20 and
they make some dumb stuff they have some
time to grow up i know your mother i
know
find that well are you saying you're
defending john gruden where do you
what's your stance can i go through my i
want one okay here's my next point
twelve points my two points
next point is this what's the value of
an apology
nothing
nada zip zilch what zero what is the
value of an apology to you
i i tend to agree with gerard that
apologizing is just nothing i won't say
it means nothing but i don't you know
what you know what is very irritating is
because when
when commentators who defend players who
are about to get fired they say give the
man a break
we've all made you know he at least
apologized what are we here judging this
man we've never done anything before so
everything is about the argument that
makes sense so delta mantras harold said
[ __ ] ass white boy to lucas okay how
how good of a ward is that by the way i
mean if you want to go through it that's
as bad as it gets okay i've been called
a bitch-ass white boy on the basketball
court
ten thousand shots should montrez
no but he's just one player i think
there's you have to distinguish between
a player like a deshawn jackson type
yeah or a meyer's landlord
or the head coach of a team who's
leading a man that's montress harold is
a grown man he's a grown man the moment
you're that age you're a grown man over
you're a grown man you're no longer a
kid he's not a leader he's a he's a
leader for his he's a leader for his
community no that's not how this works
you can't change standards on different
people bro i'm not where am i a standard
for coach and a player is the same thing
what's standard oh no i totally did okay
so that's on you though by the way it
could be a when you could have zero
standards
then it has nothing to do with the
comment so you're saying lebron james is
not the leader you're going to say the
best player of all time other than
michael jordan is yes he's a leader the
tour of the coach right yes the 12th man
that's like what manchester the 12th man
on the bench is not a leader pat it's
very clear all right and adam you've won
me over it's very very clear that what
mantras harold did was mostly peaceful
whereas these emails are clearly an
insurgency into
you know something that yeah
you need to set an example okay gruden
reportedly aimed homophobic slurs at
godel in several instances as well as
using the offensive language to describe
nfl owners coaches and media even barack
obama joe biden will reportedly mention
in gruden's email with gruden ripping
obama during his 2012 re-election
campaign and returning to biden
referring to violent biden as a nervous
clueless
what would those other four letters
after pb i don't know but anyways pixie
yeah pixie pixie uh so so look
all i'm saying is if if you're going to
put the standards of words it's got to
be across the board i disagree well
you're you're good you have the right to
disagree with that but if you're going
to say award is that offensive to a
sport stay consistent roger
i am show us the level of consistency so
any player that says something you're
cut you're what i'm trying to
i don't think you should
i don't think you should cut the guy i
think when you're in you know that
environment i don't think you should
okay
coaches are most coaches like very
proper 20 000 coaches yeah how are
coaches
loud mouse crazy you know who's scared
right now you know who's scared right
now
the ryan coach who's the ryan coach
rex ryan's got to worry right now you
know what has got to worry 90 of these
guys got to worry right now what they've
said so what are you going to do
everybody you know what just happened
the last 24 hours in the last 24 hours
probably seven million emails have been
deleted in the nfl oh my god
i did shred it shred it all right dude
everybody had a meeting and said delete
everything i was an allstate linebacker
my senior year and my coach called me
baloney tits every day in practice all
right so like come on i call you that
every day
did they fire the guy or no no
but let's go find a guy i got to tell
you man and again this is controversial
i really don't care i'm sick of people
treating black people like they have no
agency i'm sick of it like oh god how
could he possibly have said something so
horrible what happens if you use the
n-word but i did it but what he did
after you would have exactly if he did
that he did fireball
yeah if he called someone a monkey or an
ape is that fireable is it oh okay
no no in what con i'm asking you as a
black man oh you're saying that look at
me it's more smith is ape
is that fireable
if you call them the n-word that's
fireball though right okay
so words do matter but he did not so
words do matter what you're saying is
slippery slope but you're saying words
just told you
matter but for who though you've got to
be later on do words matter more if
they're said from a white person to a
black person that's what i was going to
say because i mean i'm not even looking
this as a black and white well you made
it well they literally they are they are
random misogynistic only one angle i
agree right however
myers leonard is a white guy who may say
how many times the snoop dog said the n
word
i mean that's all i'm saying dude how
many times well that's a whole nother
conversation we can have about black
people saying the n word you know
there's black people that
wholeheartedly disagree with black
people saying that and there's black
people saying no that empowers me it's a
whole we can go an hour on that topic
yeah but i like at the end of the day
there is a difference between a co like
pat you're a ceo of a company yep so use
your example
is there a big difference between you as
the ceo or matt sappala being the cdo
or alexis moody being you know marketing
direct whatever versus some random sales
person who just came to the organization
last year there's a big difference right
right chris herrell is not a random
but but there is a difference though
mantras harold's not a random okay
i'm asking you in the business context
there is a difference between the ceo
the uh c-suite executive just a regular
sales person so so for standards wise
there is do you think that is really
long
there is some set of standards that's
why i gave you credence at the beginning
where i said i think we have to give
credence to your argument i said yes i
just think there's a difference in being
a leader or a founder or a ceo but this
is a random sentence i think you have to
know when you're a player and you have
some of these players have more
followers than these coaches so that's a
great influencer not even lebron montres
harold
john gruden montres some of these
players have more followers than coaches
they're an influencer you make a comment
like that i'm sorry you're also
you're being a social media that is a
form of a leader that is a form of an
influencer that is a form of an example
ah what i know a lot of
[ __ ] models with millions and millions
of followers
but i'm not saying that they're leaders
but their leaders are taking their
clothes off in a space like we're still
getting you're saying if it's all just
based on followers absolutely like this
if you want to but but in only fans like
you're you're [ __ ] friends you're
talking about
whatever whatever you're talking about
this community right you're saying
followers doesn't mean you're a leader
but the point the point in that
community is that's across the board no
one cares this is a sport there is a
regulator at the top who his name is
roger goodell who's the commissioner he
wants to clean house to say some of
these things are not expected accept it
you got to clean it up then you've got
to keep that consistency across the
board very clear you can't just say you
can say but this person cannot say it
you gotta
why they weaponize these emails like
this i mean especially during the season
i mean there wasn't like an
investigation where you know it took
some weeks on end and you know like
there's no system in place to say
hey hey john you know this is what we
present to you you know like uh we need
to really have a chat about this you
weren't working for
you know as a coach like what pat said
what how do you feel about this because
we haven't had and he could and john
green could say why i haven't had any
interaction like this over the past 10
years
so
what are we talking about
what infractions do i have currently
with this organization well there's none
but 10 years ago you said this in this
and you know you called me a pu you know
whatever and
maybe you need some sensitivity training
this net okay so
by the way i mean what are we talking
about here like i mean do you think you
lost the locker room do you think i
don't think you lost the locker room i
mean like there would be more players
standing up and stuff like that i think
what happens i think definitely what
happens when this news comes out
look i'm 40 i'll be 42 this year i mean
we're all relatively you're the youngest
i'm not 23
i'm not 25
making 50 million or whatever
i could i could easily at me at 25 i
could say you know what i could hear
maybe from like a seasoned veteran like
you i should be pissed and maybe i just
follow i don't know
because that does happen in the locker
room what happened what happened to the
coach of the jacksonville jaguars
urban meyer versus this so well he's
if there's anybody that's excited about
this news it's him
he was all up in the news for two weeks
straight now he's no talk about a guy
who lost
that guy lost the life okay so why
because he got a lap dance from a 25
year old he didn't come back on the team
on the team flight and then he did that
bs exactly yeah what's his what's his
worst what
what urban meyer did or what john gruden
did well
honestly like if i was in the locker
room i'd be like i would
i i don't know if i would give a [ __ ]
about john which is worse
from a player's perspective from just an
actual human being's perspective see i
could give a [ __ ] if a coach called me
big lips
okay i'm just gonna say it but you care
that he got taken care of someone if you
do you care if someone called you said
you you've said this before someone
making fun of you or whatever they're
saying i got a big nose and big ears i
could give two shits
i give two [ __ ] i'm just gonna say it
sorry
but for the f-word but
i could care less okay i've been called
all kind of stuff playing ball in
college in high school oh my gosh
back then you could actually have your
coach grab you
back in the 90s and stuff so what urban
meyer did was worse
i'm saying that meyer bailed on his team
yeah i think that was that because he
didn't take a flight back with this yeah
he didn't take it back
after a loss
why because he was getting drunk with
some chick he stayed at his bar he stood
at his bar i mean okay okay so i don't
have a huge problem with whatever bro
you're right i'd be it's i'd be more
upset if i'm if i'm if his wife what the
[ __ ] were you doing yeah but if i'm his
player
you're a ceo of a company
employees are going to be like what the
hell man like you're not supposed to be
doing that you're supposed to be on the
private private back i got to take the
jet back but you don't i've got to take
the jet back that's what ends up
happening so urban wire urban meyer is
worse in your eyes than john i don't
know if again listen if if the team came
out all right and listen i'll give you
this if the team came out and they were
like you know what we can't be led by
this man i i'd say okay you know what
don't you think those conversations were
taking place according to internally
davis son of al davis bad ass dude
fire the guy or ask him to resign uh
because i think there's been some
rumbling i think there was pressure
arguably a top five receiver of all time
breakdown in tears
espn but it's a outside
i don't think it's inside the
organization i think the pressure came
from outside the organization i think
it's probably a little bit of both i
think you're right that it was
definitely outside the godels of the
world but i think internally they're
like nah how much is how much does
gruden walk away with
is it depends on how much was guaranteed
right 60 million right whatever like
that's the whole thing and if there's
any sport that is very cruel you pointy
nose [ __ ]
give me my 60 million yeah exactly i'll
take it and come here call me whatever
you want
to come don't worry tell me whatever you
want don't worry bro i got you i'll
bring you up call me pointy all you want
you know what i'm saying
man this is crazy anyway we live in a
crazy world man can you imagine how
milka toast every email from now on and
through the end of history is going to
be bro i have but what i guess here's a
different question
what's a uh what statue of limitation so
if you did it last year that's that's
wrong obviously last year
she did it you know pre-pandemic two
years ago that's that's that's still
relatively recent that's that's wrong
but five years ago is that
well is it four like what's what's the
number of years that's exciting
i'll take what you're saying and i'll
take it a step further how about like
the words that we used 10 years ago that
are considered like slurs now we're just
everyday language 10 years ago like you
talked about the f first like yeah we we
use that word all the time that f w f a
double g word and had nothing to do with
being gay it just meant like you were
like a you you were you were a wimp i
think that you know what i'm saying i
think
the three-letter word of that was very
used non-stop the six-letter word not as
you have no idea used that word before
which word
let's change it let's go to a different
story here right now businesses say as
many
businesses this is a business insider
story businesses say as many as 90 of
candidates don't turn up to job
interviews and some quit soon after
being hired you're basically hiring
anyone that would show up paul horton
closes taco restaurant down in
mid-september after being left with just
two kitchen staff members horton said
he'd spend thousands of dollars
advertising jobs at taco crush but that
only around 10 percent of applicants
replied after he hired to arrange an
interview of those he scheduled
interviews with only five percent and 10
percent turned up you can't be choosy
anymore you're basically hiring anyone
that would show up some of the
businesses insider
spoke to added that some new hires
didn't turn up to their first shift or
that they quit after just a few weeks
why would you go work today if you got
money that's coming in why would you
even go want to put that effort in there
today by the way
this is this is a uh uh interesting
thing that i'm hearing about a lot with
businesses where
can you imagine like this goes back to
standard conversation you're like dude
you are so not qualified for this job
but dude just the fact that you're
sitting here you know what you're hired
i have no other choice good help is hard
to find just let you back with nakai bro
that was just that just the fact that
you showed up that's definitely not kai
because kai is qualified but what do you
what do you think about when you hear a
story like this uh i don't think you're
gonna like what i have to say about this
to be honest with you man i think that
that quit your [ __ ] and compete you
want better employees pony up
what you
you you're you're not offering a
compensation package that's getting you
the type of employee that you want oh
nobody's gonna work today yeah i don't
know man do you think apple's having
trouble finding employees
do you think for a different job
do you think tesla's having trouble
finding those specialists go get a job
over there go you go get a job over
there go get go get no you go get a job
go get one go go get a job i don't want
a job at that point
i got a good job here
your most recent comments you might be
looking to update your resume buddy no
no but the point then becomes we already
established i could be as anti-semitic
as i want nothing will happen that's not
true buddy we'll go oh no we'll get 30
lawyers here in about seven seconds
first of all the comments he made in the
past he's done but we already know that
he comments he makes the ball over
that's a different story you got you got
working to work out by the way you know
they say that the lowest paying employee
at facebook is at like six figures they
showed it the other day the lowest paid
employee at facebook is at six figures
wow so no no no those i i did a story it
was 90 percent like some employees are
at six people everyone's making six
years however there are people making
you know fifty thousand euros you know
so but the underwriting staff but the
point is this if you want that six
figure job go learn coding and go apply
i hear you go for it but then then if
you want to open the taco bell knock off
get yourself some robots like what do
you want me to guess what this guy has
to do yeah then that taco that's a buck
99 he's got to charge four bucks for you
okay with that hey listen man are you
okay with this
are you okay with that anytime tacos go
up in price i am not okay all right the
lunch is the
lunch is too damn high pull the dough
tacos gerard just said okay gerard had
an aoc moment just like this
i think that that's a guy bitching for
no reason he's not attracted you know if
you're not attracting
talent that's a self-evaluation moment
talent to be to this whole burrito
this is the lowest of the lowest dude i
i made whoppers at burger king okay you
know how much talent it required for me
to make those whopper no onion it didn't
take a lot of talent yeah i would put
the patties from the other side and i
would line them up three okay and it
would fall off my patties would always
break so if you ever had patties that
were broken a whopper i'm i'm a big pot
i couldn't get these guys
i would try to like put them pieces
together like i'm playing this puzzle
game and then they would say no onions i
would forget i would put onions and
you're like taking a bite there's onions
right and all this other stuff but
anyways that was my job yeah i didn't
need a four-year or two-year degree well
you should pay me more than whatever i
was making at the time maybe maybe
people feel like an hour of their life
is not worth seven dollars then guess
what you know you know you know what the
business owner has to do then this
whopper is not worth the buck 99 it's
worth 3.99 and you got to pay for it but
this is this is the market you know
there's this thing called capitalism i
hear you and the math because there's
only a hundred pennies and i'll die hey
the capitalism i love capitalism but
there's land labor and capital three
different sides of course labor doesn't
have to always take it on the chin here
they do not and they do not take it on
the chin all the time so labor if labor
is telling you i don't want to do your
job
this is not a specialized position i
hear you
so then what you're suggesting is a 15
minimum wage maybe what i'm suggesting
is that this guy yeah all right should
go out of business is what i'm
suggesting if he can't attract people
all right and there's no christ and he
doesn't and he he doesn't have the
clientele no right do you know what
paying these
so first you're talking to a guy who
went out of business but you're talking
so you're talking to a guy that's you
had to
work hundreds of hours a week for 15
years to finally be able to have the
situation that you're in so i understand
the world of business and how it works
these restaurant guys margins they're
working on five percent what are you
talking about but so what pat if he is
having trouble all right attracting
employees
what is his suggestion as to what so so
let me ask you a question
but what i'm trying to tell you is this
is a basic math question and you're a
math guy okay so when you sit there and
you go through what the cost your patty
is sure what the cost of the meat is the
lettuce the tomato oh it's all going up
which is all going up the cost of real
estate the cost of rent the cost of
electricity the cost of cleaning crew
the cost of the cost of i can go on cost
of insurance cost of workers comp cost
of everything sure this ain't cheap this
is a lot of cost and then all of that
nobody else cares about your business
more than you you have to work non-stop
you're there 24 7. seven days a week
you're missing practice you're missing
time with kids you're missing all that
stuff
and your margins at restaurants are five
percent how much is welfare
so if they apply for welfare whatever
government assistance if they get paid
more with that than then yes they will
okay then so i don't know about well so
unemployment insurance
yeah so my question is okay so you say
like uh only five percent to ten percent
showed up maybe they're just going to
these businesses and saying no after
they get applied you know
just to show like yeah i tried six six
months you got to be employed for six
months before you can get on first of
all or just show that like you know like
for for someone that keeps
yeah they're like yeah you know i
applied
today guys don't even the lowest to
paying workers don't even have to go to
work
the math doesn't make it that's what i'm
getting at but but the point is when a
sackey comes out and says if business
owners decide to raise prices because of
taxes that is a unhuman thing to do
whatever comment she made like four
weeks ago we talked about it she's out
of that economist she is not an
economist neither is gerard but the
point i'm trying to make to you is you
got a five percent mark the specific
stories restaurant you got a five
percent margin in this do you know why
uh uh companies like facebook or
companies like these uh software
companies can pay what they pay you know
what their margins are what do you think
is a margin of these companies do you
don't say it i want to hear what he says
what do you think their margins are it
depends on the product but i mean their
margins are through the freaking i mean
look at apple apple doesn't develop a
[ __ ] game yeah they get and they're the
large system so how much does it take to
sustain the app
nothing you just have that platform
right they got 40
margins this guy's got a 5 margin so
it's a very different world when you're
talking about industries i agree
last year we sat there and we looked at
all our employees i sat there and i said
i want every position that i'm looking
at and these 20 percent higher paid than
we're playing right now you know what
happened to the quality people we hired
to the roof but we could now afford it
to get people like that right
seven years ago we couldn't
five years ago we couldn't now we can
here we go we brought seven c-suite
executives new we went from two or three
to seven new c-suite executives that we
have with a bigger pay with better
bonuses with better equity because now
we can afford it this restaurant guy is
not a freaking rich guy that you think
this guy's broke
he's had a rough 18 months and he's
dealing with five percent margin i don't
think that he's rich but i think that
like he's not entitled to other people's
labor
he's got to compete for people's labor
and just because he opened up a taco
shop doesn't guarantee that he's going
to be successful nobody congratulations
guys nobody's saying this but you guys
are disputing math
you've got a five percent margin you're
dealing with so if i can't he knows that
going in yeah he knows that if things
maybe it's ten percent as well
you're sitting you're talking as if
these are restaurants tens of thousands
of restaurants you go to
these guys stop tomorrow and they say
they don't want to do this anymore to
serve you you ain't got a place to go
you got to figure out a way for these
guys to also survive now margins wise if
you're saying you got to pay more no
problem but you also have to agree that
they're going to have to raise prices
they're going to be raising prices so
you're okay with that i'm not okay with
it but i'm not you can't you can
inevitability you can't say pay
employees more but don't raise money
inevitability of inflation prices are
going up anyway why would somebody
you're going to have a you're going to
have uh oh i forget the term of it um
social stratification now that there's a
term there's a term for basically it's
like a disillusioned employee right so
like bread when bread is a dollar making
seven dollars fine i'll do it when bread
is five dollars make it seven dollars an
hour they're just like screw it it's not
even worth it
it's an hour of my life for a loaf of
bread i'm not gonna work then then if
you're okay with the guy raising prices
to meet his five to ten percent margin
then he should pay more you're asking
totally if i'm okay with inflation it's
effective
increasing inflation no
you're saying to compete in a market
competing in the market is meaning i
have to go above and beyond inflation to
be able to hang with other people sure
that's two different things you're not
saying to you know raise it according to
inflation no because the guy across the
street from me that's a 50 billion
dollar fast food joint and a restaurant
i can't compete with that guy let me ask
you this one okay let me take that go
back to the same walmart and the market
across the street let me take that same
logic okay if i go up to that guy and i
say hey look your taco is four dollars
but i i only got three
it should only be three dollars that's
all i have i only make nine dollars an
hour i i can't spend half my money on
taco go elsewhere yeah those employees
are going elsewhere totally getting is
not paying enough i get this they go
elsewhere this guy's it's two you know
how much money he's gonna go elsewhere
you know how much he's got in the bank
how much do you think this guy's got in
the bank don't care
he's not entitled to being a businessman
he needs to come up with a better
business i don't disagree with the part
that many people that are business
owners shouldn't be business owners i
don't disagree with that but the basics
of math works this way if you want me to
pay you more i have to make my margin
back in the center sure you have to
raise prices if you're okay with raising
prices i'll pay you more and if if he
raises prices and the market suggests
your product sucks bingo yeah that's
okay that's not a problem if you can't
get employees you have to do something
at that point but but you just went from
one angle thinking it's just a one-angle
story it's like a five-dimensional
conversation i think that the guy
probably just
look
my thing is this man nobody is entitled
to i'm not entitled to that man's tacos
he's not entitled to this man's labor do
you know how i'm not entitled to anybody
do you know what percentage do you know
how many people work in a restaurant
business in america pre-covered you know
what that number is
i would say 40 million high i would bet
it's pretty high 40 million people you
know over 10 of you know you know how
many of them don't have a job you know
how many people in new york right now
are getting crushed because they don't
have the cash to survive you know how
many people are getting destroyed
because they can't get people to come
back to work so they're like dude i
don't even know what to do hey honey can
you come and work with me it's not
because their product sucks the climate
sucks this is not the small business
owner's fault you just say screw you get
the hell out of here i'm in the sales
business right my sales guys that go
through certain things you have to
understand the challenges they're facing
at times when we first had the code i'm
like you suck here's what you got i'm
talking about it's not how this thing
works that's how innovation works though
pat is he offering right what is he
offering paid days off what's he
offering if he can't offer more money
what's he offering
people when you're small you don't have
a lot to offer that's why it's called
small business owner 49 of americans
work for a small business i love small
business owners this guy sounds like a
bad business it's not one guy though
well they're not talking about one guy
there's plenty of guys let me say
pat it's whether this guy's got a good
business model or a bad business model
it's almost irrelevant it's the climate
that we're in what was it two-thirds of
people were getting paid more to stay
home during this pandemic than to go to
work so that's part of the climate
stimulus checks unemployment insurance
you talked about welfare
but let me say something if you're an
employee right now we've talked about
the great reset the great resignation
people are all right is this do i even
like this job maybe
we're seeing left and right
50 on the workforce is uh thinking about
changing jobs if you're an employee
right now you talked about paying your
staff 20 more i assume that's at php
um
now's the time to go get your raise i
think uh if you're if you're um an
employee typically you get what a two to
three percent raise a year
inflation you know
cost of living adjustment all that now
with inflation that's going on right now
now you should be looking for at least
the minimum five percent okay minimum
but if you're really good at what you do
you're you're talking about paying 20
more go get your money the time is now
as you know it usually the the
the um the powers in the business owner
right or in the small business hey we
create the the wages you come work for
us now
for whatever reason call it the climate
called the pandemic called everything
that's going on now's the time to go get
your money so if you're in between jobs
and you're not happy right now go get
your money and you'll you'll get what
the market pays you
yeah okay the the pain
the pain of a business owner if you're
not one you're not gonna know the pain
of the business owner if if you don't
know the pain of what a lot of these
guys are going today that are creating
jobs for people you have no clue what it
is you know when we'll hire people and
i'll and i'll judge people that work for
a company based on one basic thing
it's very easy to say
you should give that guy raise but it's
not your money
it's very easy to say we should do this
more but it's not your money and the
guys that typically eventually end up
being leaders are the guys that manage
the money as if it's their own money
this small business owner's margins are
tiny you're throwing around stuff saying
well you don't deserve to do this yes
say that to a hundred thousand
restaurants today in america they're
getting crushed so then the argument
becomes
that ubi is necessary for certain people
the argument becomes let's give some
money to certain people i'm not with
that buddy i talk to these guys
and they have probably more anxiety
panic 18 months divorces challenges kids
issues than you would even know today
because of what happened last 18 months
and now you can't even get people to go
to work yeah that's uh that's what
happens
when socialism shows up and you give
money away for free when you start doing
that workers don't show up okay all
right let's go to the next topic here uh
let's see what we got which one do we
want to go to let's pick one of these
stories uh uh uh uh uh we covered salary
let's go to 130 countries let's go page
seven
let's go to page seven corporate taxes
washington post story more than 130
countries reach deal on corporate
minimum tax uh they have agreed on
sweeping changes on how big global
companies are taxed including 15 minimum
corporate rate designed to deter
multinationals from stashing profits and
low tax countries the deal announced
friday as an attempt to address the ways
globalization and digitalization have
changed the world economy the agreement
amongst 136 countries representing 90 of
the global economy was announced by the
paris
based organization for cooperation and
economic development which hosted the
talks that led to it the oecd said that
the minimum tax would reap some 150
billion dollars for governments the
global minimum tax at 15 would apply to
companies that with more with more than
uh 864 billion dollars in revenue i
think that's a million i don't think
that no no that's a billion that's
that's annual that's worldwide billion
that is billion of course uh it's going
to go from 150 billion to 864 billion if
they apply this 15 corporate minimum tax
across 130 countries who have agreed
thoughts
here's what i want you to do because i
think as the only one who is a full-on
business owner corporate business owner
why don't you give us the good the bad
the ugly of this because you've been
pretty opinionated i don't think this
has to do i think this has to do more
with uh who who doesn't get to compete
okay so think about this how many
planets do we have to how many options
do we have on planets to live on today
we've got the earth and mars mars is
coming why shouldn't it be elon
he's probably got a little bit more time
to focus on it because his his girl was
a little bit of a distraction maybe
so but we only have one planet right i
agree okay how many countries do we have
on this planet what 200 let's say 200
countries give or take sometimes 195
sometimes 220 let's say 200 right okay
so if all of these guys all of a sudden
agree on the same corporate minimum tax
rate where do you go if you're not happy
somewhere
where do you go
what's your option now what's your
choice now what do you do now it's the
same what are the countries that aren't
signing on to this i guess that's that's
that's that's right and by the way the
one country that apple google what was
the one country
they're all in ireland right yeah now
they were 12 and a half percent they're
also agreeing and they finally went to
15 15. so what did what why are they so
excited about doing this ask that
question why are you so excited about
raising the corporate tax rate where's i
think i think yeah they want to find
that what is it though what's the motive
what's the real motive to want to do
something like this i think the the a
term you always use is a race to the
bottom so like uh
hungary is at nine percent ireland's
been at 12 and a half percent uh you
have countries like russia saudi arabia
and uh china i think was at 25 and then
you have the majority of the g7
countries somewhere around like 25 27
so
i think
you always hear an item not a corporate
tax finance guy you know that's not my
thing but you always hear about
amazon pays zero in taxes apple pays
zero in taxes
how are they getting away with this then
you hear the argument that
you you i remember you did it on the
white board with me like why are we
paying any corporate taxes because taxes
are individuals are taxed yeah i think
it's just a complicated payroll tax yeah
all that so that's why you know
the optics of it it's not only double
tax you're getting triple taxes tax on
taxes
it's non-stop it's no the money you're
making you're paying taxes on the income
you're paying tax on corporate you're
paying taxes on sales you're paying by
the time you really come to come down to
what money stays with you it's not as
big as people think it is now what the
whole thing with zero percent state zero
percent taxes they're talking about is
how a company was worth a half a billion
dollars a half a trillion dollars now
it's a 700 billion dollar company they
haven't spent the money they've made 200
billion dollars we should tax that
you know valuation of the company that
went up or your net worth went up we
should tax that additional what that you
made you didn't do anything with the
money you haven't taken it out it's just
your network's gone up right not even
capital gains there's not been an
exchange yet for the stocks to they want
to add taxes to that but i'm asking
another question here
why do you think they're so excited
about raising and making it equal to
everybody
why are they doing that what's the
motive there well when you want people
to stop smoking you increase the price
of cigarettes through taxes when you
want people to stop drinking you
increase the price of vice through taxes
you want people to get off of gas and
become carbon neutral you increase the
price i think that this is something you
talked about the small business owner
before
this is again one of the things where
only
many few few few international
corporations are going to be able to
take on the extra three four percent in
tax in addition by the way to the taxes
that they have for import and export i
mean that was one of the big things that
we have with trying china was the trade
deficit this is something i was
completely wrong about this is something
i've changed my mind 180 degrees on i
used to be completely supply side and i
said i don't care if there's a trade
deficit i don't care if china taxes our
companies 40
to import there and they and we tax them
nothing to import here that helps me the
consumer i can have six dollar underwear
instead of nine dollar on their
underwear that helps me yeah right get
your third pair under where every time
you're wrong yeah yeah off your
girlfriend's floor adam boom
yeah anyway the so
last night would you have a good time
i did hey you ditched us it better been
good we want details did she really come
visit yeah
[Laughter]
as you were saying about corporate taxes
adam we were hanging out
yeah dude long story short man like only
massive companies that have
serious government in interconnection
are going to be able to handle this on a
national level
so yeah
what's this year let me see what's going
on here i never knew that corporate tax
would be this risque
a lot of
yeah underpants at the end of the day
like we always talk about competition i
mean
big business they can compete small
can't
that's going to affect a lot of people's
way of living especially in some of
these smaller countries
you know one of the things that i've
been able to do you know being a
professional bodybuilder
was a travel world um
who's going to cheat
is what i'm thinking oh yeah you know
that's what i'm thinking right
you now
like who's going to cheat you think
china's going to play fair
great well
25 percent okay they're not in it so
are there allies is china's allies the
big domino to drop here was ireland
because ireland was was like the tax
haven for all these
major corporations at 12 and a half
percent yours and they weren't they
wanted one they want a one world
government so bad dude and they can't
see it i mean this shows it right i mean
that's exactly what this is this is
that's unelected that's the direction i
mean where's the money going to go
essentially how do they enforce it
right you know how did they enforce what
how do they enforce this yeah
what do you mean how do they enforce it
let's say we have the irs yeah but are
you talking about outside of the u.s
each of these countries have their own
taxes each of these countries is going
to get their money it's not going to be
skirting the tax laws anymore i think
that that seems to be the bottom line so
all these tax loopholes and paying zero
taxes sorry corporate uh corporations
time to pay so that seems to be the big
win for yelling advising basically i
said it so basically a country like
let's just say spain they say okay
adam uh you did in our country five
million dollars or whatever where here's
your bill and then i took a siesta
guys 150 to 895. that's how much is uh
increasing 150 to 895. that's a solid
amount that is that's six sex overnight
okay and collecting taxes it's not a bad
deal right there to make that kind of
money how are you trying to say
something
yeah i don't know how how long this is
going to go through because the thing
with cartels like that where everyone
has to be in agreement only successful
cartel there's really been over an
extended period of time is opec which
controls the oil prices but with here
all you need is one outlier to just drop
through and then all the countries are
suddenly going to start falling to that
country and they're going to be making a
lot of money that way so well there's
already countries that haven't signed on
to this yeah 136 companies countries
have we're representing what 90 of the
global economy there's still 10 percent
lingering out there so if you want to go
business and business in bangladesh have
at it
one of the major economies is not in it
i don't know no can you see if you can
pull it up in in like
30 seconds
just think about though just think about
how is this bad any improvement is this
a bad thing great
government this is a bad thing so why
would all these countries go go
sign on to this because they're greedy
and because they're working towards uh
you know
i don't think i don't think that
countries that want to uh
get that money are greedy they want that
tax revenue that's what that is greed
for what that's greed well it's the we
all want our money we're all greedy
taking tax revenue from what the people
that are earning the the money the
corporations right they're earning money
it's not like they're using so what are
they going to use this money for
whatever the hell they want as their
government right exactly kenya nigerian
pakistan and sri lanka
the only four countries that said no is
kenya nigeria pakistan and sri lanka
okay which is uh you ain't got a lot of
options yeah anyone trying to go do
business there no you ain't got a lot of
options there but i hear nightlife in
sri lanka is actually not bad i heard
your booty is where it's at though but
that's your kind of a market right
anyways hey are we doing podcast
thursday or no we are on on thursday
okay we may have a special guest with us
on thursday depending on our calendar i
don't know if we are gonna or not but
we'll see so folks uh uh stay tuned
we'll be back at it again this tuesday
uh
this thursday same time if you didn't
get a chance to watch if you're in a
bodybuilding world and if you didn't get
a chance to watch phil heath's
commentary with gerard and roy on mr
olympia that happened saturday night you
ought to go watch it if you're in the
bodybuilding community you may want to
go watch akai let's put the link below
both in the chat section
as well as the description and if you
haven't subscribed to valuetainment
sports and you're that small community
who loves sports go subscribe to
valuetainment sports take care everybody
bye bye bye
you